hello and welcome to Z 0 plane Cowell I
don't know who that is but I have a bad
score against him so let's see get the
ruler has exchanged yeah this line is
interesting especially for blitz chess
because white skin position is always a
little bit shaky we need Shawn hours
normal Bishop c5 hmm okay maybe just d3
I wonder actually click Queen d6 stir
some trickery here I move the night yeah
Queen Queen g3 check and I'm and I'm
toast that sets cool
to go Bishop f4 I guess so Bishop flower
you have to calculate the head from move
10 yeah so I cannot take now and this
especially fryer unbelievable okay so
what else Queen f3 is still Bishop
deform
what the heck also I have some some beer
deja vu like I had this before so long
this kind of kind of stuff okay I cannot
even play a 4 after Bishop before that's
crazy this is what I wanted to do oh my
so what is he doing Bishop tea for
cancelling long maybe
we should be fine I have to to take on
g6 just erm H takes and c3 something
like that maybe this isn't working for
black padded steeply irritating Bishop
c5 and stuff very strange I with all
that
so it should be in good shape here right
Oh is there anything that I'm not seeing
I should win materially IE has to go
back and then I go ping g2 and just have
everything under control so I did not
fall for any direct tactic it's still
not so easy to play because of the 97 g6
and so on is this kind of thing I
[Music]
totally hate this position check the
worst part about it is that you know
that white should should actually win I
mean this is not working objectively but
it is very tricky to play and you can
easily screw up
it looks it looks doable now position is
quite closed look edge for is probably
the relatively best try maybe I should
have taken on f4 actually we will come
to define OMI I'm actually taking f5
so what is that 3.7 pawned some two
cones up
winning is a different matter though you
have to coordinate this Kings always a
little bit a little bit shaky maybe he's
six at some point is good you sick and
then g5 I have quite now it can go look
d6 actually a couple of unprotected
pieces that is kind of unnerving here
[Music]
can I treat Queens that would be nice
probably not
yeah I'm ahead on the clock that's
really good would not so be not so not
that would not be so easy with the
little time f voice what he wants to do
time morning
it doesn't threaten much i can click
with the King check famous last words
probably know my cremeux bloody rook and
now I have to go here which I really did
not want to do
twenty-something seconds now this bloody
more I can just take I'm completely
using the threat now check check check
black forfeits on time yeah as I said
it's not so easy of course the computer
just love that stuff like that Thank of
course why this totally winning all the
time yeah but it's not easy I your king
is somewhat shaky and may be here Queen
takes a fall was actually stronger
because this is Jack green trade able
play play some look at late or so and
then we have the same position Crowley I
mean it's okay I mean it is a winning
position but you still have to convert
and your king is never safe now chandi's
f for your king edge to check pattern he
could have taken already and now this is
hell yeah we have no time and your king
is just dancing around this is of course
just a blunder but yeah so check check
lost all my lost gencos of them that
opening phase of the game that was
deeply irritating Bishop c5 here do you
three I mean you know I cannot take here
this is may check check check check yeah
this is why it took so long because I
felt sore that line and so I have to do
this i guess and i cannot go back I mean
check oops this this and he I am it it
seems to work for me but I really had to
to find all that stuff and check ya hear
everything is ok but maybe maybe I
should avoid five in the first place and
this is easier to try to look out this
bishop yeah ok this is tricky to say no
it's the position is never like if it
was corresponding the chairs wide winces
easily but the king is a constitution in
two minutes with two minutes on the
clock ok thanks for watching